you're the taken king is more than just
an expansion it's also a heart
transplant and when all is said and done
destiny is pulled through the operation
with renewed vigor and only a few scars
to show for it
Destiny's first year was a collage of
peaks and valleys as Bungie released two
expansions to a sci-fi multiplayer title
at its best
destiny was a phenomenal shooter with
pristine controls and thrilling
cooperative play but at its worst
destiny felt empty it's gorgeous world
held promise but lacked any soul
I returned to those static environments
for the chance of better gear however
slim it might be I continued long past
the point of actually having fun but the
taken King rectifies many of destiny's
problems the new light blue and
experienced systems have been revamped
to be more accessible and provide a more
rewarding overall experience light is no
longer tied to specific armor but now
it's just an average of your gears
overall value raising it is necessary
for difficult missions but when it comes
to your rank you can reach the level 40
cap through experience alone and in the
fact that loot scales with your level
and the promise of better gear is almost
always on the horizon with these new
systems in place
destiny allows you to play however you
want regardless of which missions you
want to play or how often you want to
play them you can play cooperative
strikes explore Mars or fight through
the expansions excellent new story
missions these quests follow our
Guardians and their fight against Oryx
the hive Cain whose presence has cast a
shadow over things for some time now and
for the first time these story missions
are coherent providing much-needed
context to the quests our Guardians
embark upon I always knew the mission
objective and always felt the pull of
that final battle with a taken king at
the end of the road and the story is
spurred on with vivid characterization
the vanguard leaders are more than just
talking mannequins now with
personalities motivations and fears of
their own nolan north delivers a stellar
performance as your ghost but it's
cayde-6
the hunter captain who stands out
ah taken eros get your rock off my map
voiced by Nathan Fillion his sarcasm and
sardonic wit are just facades they
slowly give way to doubt and remorse as
he learned to the death old friend and
for the first time
destiny shows signs of humanity in its
storytelling ironic considering cayde-6
isn't human
fighting through these story missions is
more varied than ever before it's not
just about endless shooting at cookie
cutter enemies the taking our ghosts
like clones of destinies other factions
which Oryx has absorbed into his own
army creating a force with a wide array
of abilities and attacks fallen
captain's blind you cabal mercenaries
force blast with her shield and vex
goblins shield their allies forcing you
to aim for one specific run at a time
Destiny's combat is now more dynamic and
more versatile than the skirmishes of
its first year the strike bosses in the
taken King follow suit and require
teamwork and tactics to defeat
the taking Kings PvP modes and maps are
excellent as well rift places a spark at
the center of the map and much like a
neutral capture-the-flag match both
teams must bring it in to the enemy base
mayhem on the other hand the most
creative new variant grants increased
super energy resulting in chaotic
display of flaming hammers electric
storms and void arrows sailing through
the air these modes play out across
eight new Maps each with their own
varied sight lines and verticality
Bungie once again has proven its prowess
with multiplayer level design and then
there's the new raid it's called king's
fall and it's the most expansive in
destiny to date it begins on a sour note
with ill-advised first-person
platforming but soon gathers speed
thereafter the checkpoints all required
careful teamwork and the bosses are some
of the most creative Bungie has ever
designed I don't want to spoil too much
about the six-person Trek but its final
boss both in size and scope is colossal
he's a fitting end to Destiny's most
dynamic raid yet but despite all the
improvements the destiny system's all
the new content and places to take in
King and all the heart that's gone into
this compelling storyline remnants of
Destiny's past still remain after
sixteen hours of the expansion the grind
began at first I didn't mind the taken
King excels in granting you gear through
hard work rather than luck but I played
the same strikes five times over day in
and day out i trudged through the
Dreadnought for hours on end i completed
similar bounties throughout the week and
didn't see many variations throughout 35
hours of the taken king for a game that
requires so much grinding it still
doesn't have the foundation to support
the repetition required the promise of
better loot is the driving force but the
journey there is taxing quests are
interesting only for a time but after a
while they once again become long list
of cloying chores but the taken King
still deserves ample praise it not only
grants us new content but reinvigorates
a game that otherwise lost its way in
one of the expansions early story
missions you'll come across the remains
of Destiny's very first strike boss he's
right where you left him surrounded by
his own robotic innards the life long
gone from his dormant shell and like the
Guardians who killed that boss destiny
has since moved on there are still
traces of its mediocre first year but
destiny is now more vital more promising
with much of its rotting corpse left
behind
remember when suffix Prime was our
biggest problem